[Musique]
les militants pro choix de ces louis
tente d'organiser la résistance mais ils
peinent encore à croire que l'état du
missouri a complètement béni
l'avortement d'un timing mais comme
je sais qu'ils crient victoire mais ils
n'arriveront pas alors sein du bob kane
quand vous allez voir toute la misère
que cela va provoquer quand les femmes
doivent traverser les frontières de
l'état et que ceux qui les aideront
iront en prison là ça va leur tomber
dessus comme une tonne de président
pour avoir accès à l'avortement les
femmes de saint-louis devront traverser
le mississippi et se rendre dans l'état
voisin en illinois où l'avortement est
toujours légale mais où que transports
en commun et accessible pour s'y rendre
la clinique d'avortement recrute donc
des volontaires pour assurer le
transport sindup
n'a pas hésité à se porter volontaires
et l'ira volonté chercher les femmes du
missouri qui souhaitent se faire avorter
en illinois parce qu'elle se souvient
trop bien de ce qu'était la vie avant le
jugement road contre wade dit la
retraite est mort
mais même en arrivant la clinique la
partie n'est pas gagnée des militants
anti avortement montent la garde à
l'entrée
la plus importante clinique d'avortement
au sud de l'illinois juste en face nous
avons donc toujours des conseillères
qu'ils offrent des ressources et nos
bureaux sont à exactement cent trente
deux pieds de la clinique explique le
directeur général de coalition for life
l'organisme compte soixante-dix mille
militants anti avortement ou missouri et
en illinois est ici chaque avortement
éviter est une victoire
[Musique]
nous offrons à chaque cliente une séance
photo après l'accouchement toutes ces
femmes ont considéré l'avortement mais
elles ont finalement choisi la vie dit
brian westbrook coalition for life d'y
venir en aide à 700 femmes chaque année
car nous accrochons leurs photos aux
murs ça nous rappelle l'importance de ce
que nous faisons et puis les locaux sont
équipés d'une chapelle qui a une vue
directement sur la clinique d'avortement
s'il fait froid dehors nous bénévoles
peuvent venir prier ici avec la décision
de la cour suprême coalition for life
souhaite s'agrandir et étendre ses
activités jusqu'à chicago
il y a dix huit inédits d'avortement là
bas alors on veut être présent devant
chacune d'elles mais les militants pro
choix de l'illinois ont aussi des
projets d'expansion et une nouvelle
clinique d'avortement ouvrira bientôt
près de charleroi à cabinda
l'idée est d'aider les femmes du sud des
états unis où l'accès à l'avortement
sera de plus en plus difficile ce sera
la clinique la plus proche pour ces
femmes au nord du kentucky j'y serai et
bénévoles lorsqu'elle va ouvrir conclut
sharon et si valérie gamache
radio-canada belleville et linois